very quietly and without much notice or
fanfare from corporate media Bernie
Sanders has taken a pretty decisive
position in second place of the 2020
Democratic primary ahead of Elizabeth
Warren and is actually even
statistically tied for first place with
Joe Biden in admittedly just one recent
poll if you look at the last eight polls
as of a few hours ago Bernie Sanders is
either statistically tied for second
place with Elizabeth Warren in two of
the polls 14 13 and 16 17 or in second
place behind Joe Biden Bernie polling as
high as 25 in the latest Emerson poll as
low as 14 in the latest USA Today poll
but in that USA Today poll where Bernie
pulls 14 Elizabeth Warren pulls 13 this
has not been covered very much or even
really almost at all by corporate media
I took a look at Google News and saw
that there's an article from Vox saying
most voters haven't picked anybody yet I
saw an article from Newsweek which
accurately says Joe and Bernie are
pulling away there's one good piece in
The Boston Globe saying Bernie is back
and has a shot at this thing now of
course we don't know what will happen
but Bernie Sanders is suddenly in a very
strong position in national polling with
all of the normal caveats the caveat of
course is much like with national
polling related to Donald Trump we need
to understand that this is an electoral
college race in the end the primary also
is made up of delegates that are
garnered looking at each individual
States primary or caucus so let's look
at some of those first primary States
and you know when you do that it's also
not looking bad for Bernie in those
first primary states bernie is in a
statistical tie for first place in Iowa
which is the first state to vote Bernie
is in third place in New Hampshire
behind Biden and Budaj Bernie's tied
with Elizabeth Warren for second place
in Nevada and Bernie is tied with
Elizabeth Warren for second place in
South Carolina which will be the fourth
state to vote so I get a lot of emails
that are you know this black and white
thinking of
either all this or all that Bernie's
gonna win all these Bernie's gonna win
none of these this could go any number
of ways and it's going to be based on
the momentum set by the early states so
if you're with Bernie start to focus on
Iowa and New Hampshire and subsequently
Nevada and South Carolina if you are
with whoever increasingly that is the
strategy we had debate number six last
night
we have debate number seven on January
14th and then voting starts on February
3 with the Iowa caucuses eight days
later it will be the New Hampshire
primary on February 11th so can Bernie
Sanders win that's one question that's
often discussed the answer is yes he can
win what are you getting at when you
asked that question are you alluding to
DNC opposition to Bernie are you
alluding to voters taking to the
ideology espoused by Bernie Sanders
depending on what you're asking there's
a different political analysis to be
made will Bernie win anybody claiming
that definitively is operating in mere
speculation so I get a lot of Andrew
yang supporters who will get in touch
and say David yang will win the
nomination and is the only person who
can defeat Donald Trump neither one of
those claims is based in fact I get
people who say David tulsi gabbard is
being railroaded but she would have won
obviously if it weren't for the smears
against her and she is the only one who
can defeat Donald Trump we went through
some of these claims before these are
all mere speculation what we can say
about Bernie Sanders is that he is in
this thing he is in this thing even
within the first four primary states
that will be sort of like the momentum
setters and at least in hypothetical
polling with Donald Trump Bernie does
well he does better than many candidates
and he does worse than Joe Biden and in
some polls worse than Elizabeth Warren
nationally although I'm trying to be as
full as possible here in thorough at in
some key states Bernie Sanders does
better than Elizabeth Warren in a
hypothetical matchup against Donald
Trump so go and work for it because it's
going to take
work this is going to be if you were to
say will we know by March first who the
nominee is going to be and whether it's
going to be Bernie Sanders I don't know
that we will know by March first but I
think that by March 15th we will know
I'm going from memory I believe very
early in March maybe the third or
something like that there are a bunch of
primaries including I think here in
Massachusetts
once those happen we're going to have a
very good sense of who is in this thing
who is not in this thing and who should
be dropping out because they have not
garnered maybe even any delegates in any
of the first bunch of primaries so we
will certainly know by that last thing
on this the role of impeachment in all
of this there's this idea that once the
impeachment trial starts in the Senate
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren are
going to be pulled out of their
campaigns and in the Senate for the
trial and this will objectively hurt
them and it will boost Biden and or
Budaj edge the more establishment
candidates I don't know that that is
actually going to happen you can
speculate over whether that's the goal
of impeachment I think it's not I think
that Donald Trump is getting impeached
because Donald Trump deserves to get
impeached and there's going to be a
trial I don't believe that the full
slate of democratic challengers in a
democratic voters democratic reps who
voted for impeachment in the House of
Representatives are saying here's an
idea I'm going to vote to impeach Trump
to get Bernie and Warren off the trail
so that Biden becomes the nominee I
don't think that that's the case but
it's speculative the more important part
is would it actually work and I think
that in a way you could be right that
not being on the campaign trail could
hurt Bernie or Warren but remember most
of what is going to be going on by the
time the Senate trial starts is going to
be via TV ads and campaigning that
doesn't require them to physically be
where the voters are and furthermore
there's a way in which being prominently
participating in the Senate trial of
Donald Trump's impeachment could
actually help Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders that Joe Biden won't have
the benefit of that Peabody judge will
not have the benefit of so I would not
jump to that right away
I don't think that there is actually
evidence of the motive and more
importantly I think if it is the
strategy that some are pursuing to get
Bernie and Warren off of the campaign
trail I think it is going to fail and
it's going to not not work at all and
could even backfire we are going to talk
about many things coming up later today
including I want to get I never talked
about this but I do want to talk about
it
Baron Trump and Greta toon burg why is
it that Republicans went nuts when one
was mentioned but said nothing about
Donald Trump bullying the other online I
want to talk about that a little bit
later we will get back to this
conversation of martial law and
contesting the election results I want
to get to that later in the show also a
really weird question related to my
recent appendectomy that I had which I'm
going to humor the viewers with and
actually answer later today we will also
take your phone calls upcoming make sure
you are following me at D Pakman on
Twitter follow the david pakman show at
david pakman show and we've got a
tremendous tremendous friday show for
you i will remind you just so people
don't forget we have the monday show and
then we're on break until almost the end
of the year we're taking a week off next
week don't get scared the show is now
going off the air we're just taking a
little vacation i am thrilled to tell
you that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman Blink
astiz a really unique service for your
phone tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka steaks the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks i'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
seven day free trial
by going to blink is calm / Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube I've put a
link in the description I have listened
to blinka spokes about economics about
political science about history about
science so many interesting things and
after the free trial if you like it you
can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to blink is calm /
Pakman that's be Li NK is t.com /pa ke
ma n